[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren haben sie sich auch schon gefragt
wie aus diesem klumpen materie einig
entstehen kann mit wahrnehmungen mit
gefühlen und gedanken
vermutlich ist das eines der größten
rätsel der menschheit
mein heutiger gast aber sieht das anders
denn internet ist eine der
einflussreichsten philosophen weltweit
er ist atheist darwin ist und ein
anhänger des naturalismus
für ihn sind wir menschen nicht mehr aus
ein komplexes stück materie
mal sehen wo gott die seele und unsere
freiheit da bleiben herzlich willkommen
zu sein
ja die großen philosophen platon und
aristoteles meinten die philosophie
beginnt mit dem staunen
wann haben sie das letzte mal
philosophisch gestaunt als ich musste
wieder das tue ich fast jeden tag
manchmal staune ich über die generalität
der natur manchmal ganz einfach über
seltsame gegebenheiten im universum und
dann wieder staune ich über falsche
vorstellungen einiger kollegen die es
einfach nicht kapieren
ich bin zum schluss gekommen sie
verstehen gewisse dinge nicht weil sie
sie nicht verstehen wollen
sie wollen ihnen ihr geheimnis lassen
sie haben ein fast moralisches prinzip
übernimmt jan ich denn jetzt sichtweise
das ist der glitschige abgrund in die
höhe
darüber werden wir sprechen nicht
interessiert jetzt aber sie sind ja
eigentlich jemand der diese dieses
mysteriöse dieses rätselhafte entzaubert
sie sind der große entzauberung und
sagen eigentlich ist das alles
prinzipiell wissenschaftlich erklärbar
es geht aus mit rechten dingen zu es
gibt nichts übernatürliches wann hat das
bei ihnen eigentlich angefangen
diese einsicht wann haben sie das
eingesehen schon in jungen jahren als
teenager
ich weiß noch wie ich dekkers
meditationen glaskugel ergo sum ich
denke also bin ich und mich mit seinem
dualismus befasste
damals war ich 17 ich war fasziniert
davon aber ich urteilte spontan wie man
das in diesem alter tut das ist schön
aber falsch ich finde auch heraus warum
dafür brauche ich nicht mehr als ein
zwei nachmittage 50 jahre später bin ich
immer noch auf der suche
ich meine ich frage mich auch wie sind
sie aufgewachsen mein umfeld war ihre
familie auch so naturwissenschaftler und
atheistischen sie waren keine
naturwissenschaftler
mein vater war historiker
islamwissenschaftler meine mutter war
englischlehrerin ihr betätigungsfeld
waren die humanwissenschaften hingegen
war schon als kleiner junge an der
naturwissenschaft interessiert aber
während meiner schulzeit ging mein
interesse nicht über den regulären
unterrichtsstoff hinaus vor meinem
studien besuchte ich keine eigentlichen
naturwissenschaftlichen kurse ein
wissenschaftliches pflichtpensum deckte
ich mit logik hosen in gewisser weise
doch in unserer stadt in humans
besuchten alle kinder die sonntagsschule
es gab viele protestantische und eine
katholische kirche
ich besuchte die komplikation allis
tische kirche diese war schon damals in
den 1940 er und 50er jahren äußerst
liberal und gruselig und alles andere
als doktrin
ich wurde mit zahlreichen fällen
den büchern der bol vertraut lernte
unzählige lieder und sang in vielen
kurden noch heute liebe ich geistliche
chormusik und fast alles habe ich selber
oft gesungen
doch ich nahm das glaubensbekenntnis nie
richtig ernst
andererseits hatte ich auch keine
atheistische erleuchtung
ich möchte einfach dass ich nicht daran
glaubte ein wichtigtuer richer
selbstherrlicher pfarrer den ich
verabscheute trug dazu bei
nur schon dass ich ihn für einen
aufgeblasenen depp hielt verstärktem
eine faszination für den atheismus
[Gelächter]
brechen
jetzt möchte ich anfangen mit dem hier
mit diesen gruppen materie und für mich
ist das ein unglaublich großes rätsel
und sie sind der führende experte oder
einer der führenden experten wenn es um
unser bewusstsein geht sie sind
philosophie professor und direktor des
zentrums für kognitionswissenschaft an
der tufts university in der nähe von
boston in den usa können sie sich da
noch an den moment erinnern als sie zum
ersten mal gedacht haben was für ein
rätsel dass daraus ein ich entsteht ein
bewusstsein steht gefühl entstehen kann
ich weiß noch wie ich im college darüber
nachdachte vor allem über unsere
visuelle wahrnehmung
schon damals fiel mir auf dass viele
irrtümlicherweise annehmen in ihrem kopf
laufe irgendwie ein film eine art
inneres ich dachte das kann nicht
stimmen
das ist auf subtile weise unlogisch aber
ich fand nichts positives mit dem ich
diese vorstellung ersetzen konnte
bereits damals beschäftigte mich also
diese idee zu nehmen
als ich dann in oxford an der
universität war hatte ich einen freund
der medizin studierte ich wusste damals
rein nichts über das gären und fragte
ihn woraus besteht das gehirn aus
neuronen was sind neuronen ich weiß noch
wie er sich auf den boden setzte ein
stück papier nahm eine zeichnete und es
mit einem weiteren neuen verband und er
erzählte mir das wichtigste was 1963
über neuerungen bekannt war
da hatte ich eine dramatische erkenntnis
mehr wurde schlagartig bewusst dass
waren einheiten die man in großen
netzwerken mit anderen verwinden konnte
um durch eine evolution im gehirn
lernprozess das gehirn ist ein
wunderbares lern gerät und wie ist es
möglich ohne geheimnisse zusammen ohne
einen wissenden lehrer in uns drin der
uns den weg sei
es ist ein prozess von versuch und
irrtum indem man mehr oder weniger
hirnlos herum tastet bis nun
verbindungen findet die funktionieren
und dann baut man diese immer weiter aus
schon 1963 hatte ich die vorstellung
lernen sei eine evolution im gehirn
später entdeckte ich dann dass ich mit
meiner annahme nicht der erste zweite
oder dritte war auch charles darwin
hatte ähnliche ideen
heute ist man sich so ziemlich einig der
prozess des lernens entdeckens und
erfindens im gehirn kann mechanisch
ausgedrückt heruntergebrochen werden auf
kaskaden von versuch und irrtum
prozessen die sich einen wettkampf wobei
die gewinner dem organismus besser beim
verstehen helfen als die verlierer
helbing registrieren man merkt schon
dieses modell der evolutionstheorie
spielt bei ihm überall eine rolle sie
erklären auch kulturelle phänomen
religion so und beim gehirn sagen sie es
ist sozusagen die magie wenn es sie denn
gibt oder der trick funktioniert durch
die verbindung zwischen einzelnen
nervenzellen neuronen aber ich frage
mich jetzt haben sie gesagt lernen das
kann man erklären dass kann mir
vorstellen dass dann die verbindung
zwischen einzelnen neuronen sozusagen
gestärkt werden aber bewusst sein dass
erleben eine ich perspektive zu haben
und dieser welt schmerzen zu haben
liebe zu empfinden und so weiter wie
kommt kommen diese materiellen medialen
phänomene zustande aus diesem material
das ist das große leib seele problem
oder das problem beheben geist und
gehirn zusammenhängen
wo entsteht denn das bewusstsein hier
drin und wie steht das nehmen wir das
was viele menschen am meisten fürchten
schmerz und leidenschaft
unser körper unser nervensystem ist mit
so genannten und sektoren ausgestattet
diese zellen nehmen schmerz oder
gefahren
sie können auch viel gezündet werden
aber so werden schmerzsignale ausgelegt
physiologisch und neuro anatomisch ist
der verlauf der schmerz fasern bis ins
gehirn recht gut erforscht und allgemein
akzeptiert doch was passiert im gehirn
wie spürt man schmelzen im gehirn
offensichtlich ist es nicht so dass
seine hohen anderen neuronen mit einer
kette schlägt und ihnen so schmerzen
zufügt einzelne neuronen spüren keinen
schmerz wie entsteht also durch die
interaktion von
neuronen im ganzen organismus dass es
schmeckt sie ist anspruchsvoll aber wir
können eine antwort zumindest skizzieren
sie hätten keine notiz touren wenn sie
nicht nützlich werden diese
schmerzrezeptoren bewilligten dass wir
unterbrechen was wir gerade tun und
unsere prioritäten anders setzen wenn
sie ohne schmerz fähigkeit auf die welt
kämen wären sie stark behindert es gibt
menschen die von geburt auf kein
schmerzempfinden haben ihr leben ist
kurz und traurig daher haben wir
schmerzrezeptoren unter anderem ist ihre
funktion mit einem signal dass alle
anderen über bord zu unterbrechen was
wir gerade das geschieht ohne einen
zentralen normen kurs er entscheidet was
als nächstes zu unternehmen ist es muss
also ein wettkampf stattfinden zwischen
dem schmerz und dem was sie gerade
beschäftigt der schmerz sehr stark ist
gewinnt er den wettkampf
was ist also dieser wettkampf
physiologisch nichts anderes als die
differenziale produktion von eur
modulatoren die entweder etwas behindern
oder begünstigen
wir wissen dass es im gehirn viele
entgegengesetzte prozesse gibt er eine
zieht der andere zieht und der
kompromiss ist das was man tut so
funktionieren ihre augenmuskeln
gegensätzlich zueinander und bestimmen
wohin sie schauen
nehmen wir ein einfaches beispiel in
ihrem alltag bewegen sich ihre augen
drei bis vier mal pro sekunde
sie springen hin und her ohne dass sie
es merken was bestimmt wohin ihre augen
springen ein wettkampf zwischen den
neuronen die einen sagen wie langweilig
das kenn ich zeig mir was neues
andré sein trautes heim ich will hier
bleiben wird der zug auf einer seite
stärker kommt es zu einem blick bewegung
das geht sehr schnell fünf mal pro
sekunde sei das alles versteht da habe
ich zu verstehen
das erklärt aber nur warum ich die hand
schnell wegziehen
das hat evolutionäre vorteile wenn die
platte heißt ist damit ihr verletzte
aber nehmen wir dieses glas wasser hier
also ich meine dass besteht auch aus
molekülen h2o die selbst ein molekül ist
nicht flüssig aber ganz viele davon sind
durchsichtig und flüssig es entsteht
eine neue qualität beim bewusstsein beim
gehirn ist das vielleicht ähnlich es
entsteht aus diesem verbund von
nervenzellen plötzlich schmerzempfindung
wasser bis völlig anders das
interessiert mich wie kommen sie dahin
das muss ich als nächstes erklären
und ich tue das gehirn hat ein problem
es besteht aus 86 milliarden neuronen
und diesel sind zu allen möglichen fähig
es braucht also etwas das alles
vereinfacht etwas das die aktivitäten
große neuronen gruppen umformt damit sie
einfache dinge darstellen
dieses phänomen erinnert an eine
technische errungenschaft die ingenieure
erst kürzlich entwickelt haben nämlich
die benutzeroberfläche von computern
oder smartphones ihr handy ist ein
unglaublich kompliziertes gerät schicht
um schicht software hardware und
firmware aus milliarde teilchen genauer
wollen sie das gar nicht wissen
sie wollen einzig eine auf metaphern
basieren der benutzeroberfläche einfach
irgendwie illusorisch man spricht daher
auch vom benutzer illusion
doch wäre es der benutzer das bin ich
und das handy vermittelt mir eine
illusion
aber es ist eine gutartige willkommene
illusion wenn sie vereinfacht ihr leben
lang ihr können sie ihr handy
kontrollieren und damit tun was sie
wollen
das ist die idee das gehirn verfügt über
eine eigene benutzer illusion
das heißt es es vereinfacht den input
der regulieren muss was ich als nächstes
tun und das resultat sind sie dass
bewusstes subjekt das aus dieser
interaktion zwischen den benutzer
flächen der beiden gehirnhälften
hervorgeht
das geschieht nicht an einer stelle im
gehirn
es gibt viele bereiche wo diese
kompromisse und vereinfachungen
ausgearbeitet werden
die handlungen und reaktionen auslösen
oder entscheidungen und identifikationen
herbeiführen er uns das vorstellen
auf diese weise wird signalisiert wo der
schmerz sitzt und wie stark er ist
über all das ist eines der zentralen
themen meiner arbeit seit mehr als 25
jahren
es gibt keine stelle im gehirn wo alles
zusammenkommt und das bewusstsein sitzt
ich bezeichne es als kategorisches
theater für descartes war es die
zirbeldrüse im zentrum des gehirns eine
art fakt verbindung zur seele durch die
angst durch muss um bewusst zu werden
verrückte idee auf brillante weise
verrückt es gibt keinen solchen ort was
der intelligente weise geschätzte
homunculus anscheinend im kontrollraum
leistet muss verteilt werden auf
neuronale instanzen die kein bewusstsein
haben aber diese arbeit leisten
das ganze ist ziemlich
gewöhnungsbedürftig das heißt eigentlich
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe dass ich
und da auch empfindungen wie schmerz
sind eigentlich illusionen die das
gehirn erzeugt damit das einfache
arbeiten kann und nicht diese
komplexität irgendwie bewältigen muss es
bietet repräsentation der welt sehen sie
nicht dankbar für diese illusion
ich habe die evolution hat sie auf
brillante weise geschaffen als
zusammenfassung als metapher dafür was
wirklich geschieht aber wissen sie was
das problem ist für mich dass ich denke
dass mein geist mein wille keinen
einfluss dann haben kann auf meinem
körper also wenn ich doch sage ich
möchte jetzt meinen rechten arm heben
und kann ich das tun
und dieser wunsch der gedanke war doch
zuerst und dann hat sich das gehirn und
der arm in bewegung gesetzt aber das
funktioniert doch einfach nicht in ihrem
modell also wie funktioniert diese
mentale tatsächlich funktioniert das
nicht in meine mutter denn sie stellen
sich dass ich als separaten bereich oder
unter bewohnern des gehirns
das ich umfasst wenn sie so wollen das
ganze gehen und die umsetzung ihrer
wünsche und erwartungen beinhalten viele
prozesse in raum und zeit
dadurch wird bestimmt wann ihre hand
hoch geht das gehirn vor allem das
menschliche verfügt über eine
eigenschaft die nicht genügend gewürdigt
wird zumindest nicht von
wissenschaftlern vielleicht von dichtern
die darstellungsmöglichkeiten des
bewussten denkens sind gigantisch
sie scheinen grenzenlos geld das denken
sogar die sprache in den schatten
wie oft sagt man was ich fühle kann ich
nicht in worte fassen
es gibt ein unglaubliches repertoire
verschiedener zustände technisch
ausgedrückt sind dies die gerade der
freiheit
jeder gedanke ist ein grad der freiheit
themen kontrollieren muss doch es sind
zu viele
es gibt milliarden freiheitsgrade im
menschlichen gehirn wie kann also
irgendetwas je irgendwas kontrollieren
so wie funktioniert der prozess der
autonomie wie kann ein gehirn einen
autonomen akteur schaffen ist der
autonomie akteur eine rate vereinfacht
das gehirn in erster linie und
vermittelt nur eine kleine anzahl
mögliche aktionen sich verstecken
schlafen sich fortpflanzen kämpfen
fressen etwas fressbares erjagen das ist
so ziemlich alles
es gibt nur fünf freiheitsgrade ich kann
wählen zwischen abc.de mehr sind es
nicht
es gibt kein fg und höchstens varianten
von a b c d und e doch im unterschied
dazu ist die zahl der dinge die wir
jederzeit tun können
gigantisch irgendwie und daran arbeite
ich momentan irgendwie ist das
fortgeschrittene systeme prozesse zu
schaffen die bestimmen was sie als
nächstes denken wie sie ihre
entscheidungen umsetzen
ist also alles vorbestimmt
aber durch die aktivitäten des systems
dh es ist autonom
aber das heißt nicht nur die die das ich
und das erleben ist eine illusion die
das gehirn erzeugt sondern auch die
freiheit dass wir sozusagen entscheiden
und eingreifen können dass wir sozusagen
die dirigenten sind die das gehirn
orchestrieren dirigieren das ist auch
nicht der fall für sie ist sozusagen das
wir jetzt
man könnte sagen und manche leute
fliehen mich an ist zu sagen weil sie es
hören wollen
der freie wille ist eine illusion
teilweise gibt es die benutzer illusion
ihr gehirn ist dazu geschaffen ihnen und
sie sind mehr als das gehirn
möglichkeiten zu präsentieren aus denen
sie wählen können und welche möglichkeit
sie wählen wird bestimmt durch das
zusammenspiel von erfahrungen aus ihrer
erziehung von wünschen und schwächen
davon ob sie betrunken sind und viele
mehr
sie haben eine art arena in der
entscheide gefällt werden
und diese sind nicht vorbestimmt
auch korrekt funktionierenden computer
fällen entscheide
obwohl sie vor bestimmte systeme sind
sie wenden ein das sind aber keine
realen entscheiden
versuchen sie mal die kompetenz von
korrekten computerprogrammen zu
verstehen ohne diesen reale
entscheidungen zu zerstören man kann
sagen die treffen entscheidung aber ich
würde sagen es sind keine freien
entscheidung also wenn sie sagen wir
können auch in einer determinierten welt
in der alles durch kaiser gesetze
festgelegt ist frei sein
stell mir so wie billardkugeln treffen
aufeinander und so weiter das ist auch
in unserem gehirn so dann ist eigentlich
und wir sind der teil der denn der
natürlichen welt mit unserem gehirn dann
ist doch seit dem urknall steht fest
dass wir beide jetzt hier sitzen und
miteinander philosophieren und das kann
ich doch nicht dass das freiheit zu
nennen ist doch absurd
platz ist eine bekannte weit verbreitete
ansicht unser beruht auf einem 2000
jahre alten fehler nämlich der idee dass
willensfreiheit falls es diese überhaupt
gibt im widerspruch steht zum
determinismus und ich sage das stimmt
nicht
vorausgesetzt es gibt willensfreiheit
ein beispiel aus der geschichte dass ich
vor vielen jahren in meinem ersten buch
ellbogenfreiheit beschrieben habe das
viking raumschiff wurde von der erde
richtung mars geschossen
an einem gewissen punkt dauerten die
signale von der raketenbasis bis zum
raumschiff zu lange für eine praktische
kontrolle
damit hatten die ingenieure gerechnet
sie schalteten ihre kontroll signale aus
und ließen das raumschiff autonom
agieren es kontrollierte sich also
selber ist weder mysteriös noch
metaphysisch
die kontroll theorie aus der technik
zeigt deutlich den unterschied zwischen
das b kontrolliert und b das spiel
kontrollierte selbstkontrolle ist
unabhängig vom vorbestimmung
selbstkontrolle in diesem imitierten
ingenieurwissenschaftlichen sinn beginnt
mit etwas recht einfachem wie den viking
raumschiff der möbel oder aber je mehr
gerade der freiheit man hinzufügt desto
interessanter und wichtiger wird die
vorstellung von unabhängigkeit
denn sobald ein system fähig ist
milliarden unterschiedliche dinge zu tun
um selber eine auswahl zu treffen hängen
diese entscheidungen vom
entwicklungsstand des gehirns ab das
wiederum hängt von der geschichte und
von den genen aber es wird nicht von
kräften der umwelt gesteuert sondern
einzig vom momentanen zustand des
gehirns das nicht mehr als ein computer
ist das ist eine art von selbständigkeit
und wenn wir von organismen wie den
menschen sprechen hat das sogar
moralische dimension
daraus folgt doch auch dass das auch
künstliche systeme wie im computer
roboter frei sein können freiheit haben
können aber auch bewusstsein haben
können
ich verstehe so dass wenn diese objekte
sich so verhalten als ob sie frei wären
oder bewusstsein haben gefühle haben
wünsche haben dann haben sie es auch
mehr muss doch nicht sein
es stimmt dass in der praxis müsste ein
roboter eine künstliche intelligenz
allerdings unendlich komplex
ausgestattet sein damit er wie wir
moralisch hand und kennt b grundsätzlich
stimmt es auf die frage gibt es bewusste
roboter antworte ich seit jahren klar
ich bin einer wie sie auf wir sind
roboter die roboter entstammen die
roboter menschen auf der subsidiären
ebene gibt es kleine protein roboter wie
geben so potter
sie haben keinen metabolismus sind also
nicht mehr als kleine roboter so sind
wir
wir bestätigen uns unmengen solcher
roboter ich bin noch etwas anderes aus
dieses iphone mit der serie drauf mit
der ich vielleicht irgendwann mit zehn
jahren schon in fünf jahren sprechen
kann wie mit ihnen aber diese serie hat
auch kein bewusstsein die hat doch kein
kein erleben und keine freiheit das ist
doch wirklich sagen noch nicht
und wenn wir sie tatsächlich mit einem
bewusstsein ausstatten würden würde es
die fähigkeiten der software verdoppeln
verdreifachen oder vervierfachen
nein sie wäre nur um 100
grössenordnungen komplizierter und das
sollte man ernst nehmen hat eine amöbe
einen bewusstsein
sie lebt hat aber kein nervensystem
sie besteht aus einer zelle war aber die
chemischen reaktion zyklen in der amöbe
sind eine art nervensystem dass ihr
verhalten steuert sie ist in einem
erstaunlichen ausmaß autonom und
verteidigt sich genau das tut jedes
neuron in ihrem
3 richtig und wir bestehen aus billionen
von amöben nebel das in roboter wie sie
sagen
sie reagieren nur auf äußere reize aber
sie haben absichten verbindet man
genügend amöben miteinander bekommt man
große verbände wie auf ihren inneren
zustand reagieren indem sie ihn
beobachten bewerten und zukünftige
zustands formen imaginieren das alles
kann man individuell einfügen in die
rechnerischen verbindungen zwischen den
neuronen und gliazellen das gehirn ist
ein wunderbar kompliziertes gebilde
keine künstliche intelligenz kann es
betreffend komplexität nur annähernd mit
ihm aufnehmen man sieht schon diese
vergleich zu den computer sozusagen
unser geist die software ist das gehirn
die hardware der ist irgendwie ganz
stark ich habe ein prinzipielles problem
war ich immer noch nicht verstehen wie
dieses phänomenale die sich qualia diese
erlebens qualitäten die es ist ein
schluck wasser zu trinken zum beispiel
wie es ist wenn ich mich hier berühren
wie das zustandekommen es gibt berühmte
gedankenexperimente in der philosophie
die versucht haben ein argument zu
machen gegen diese art von
funktionalismus oder physikalisch muss
den sie vertreten muss ich sagen
letztlich gibt es doch eigentlich glaube
materien ein ganz berühmtes heißt mary
das stammt von frank jackson und wir
haben uns wir haben das animiert in der
reihe viel los so fix und wir schauen
uns das kurze zusammen an
[Musik]
dieses war billiger etwas befindet sich
unter der schädeldecke ein faltiger
wackelpudding bestehend aus milliarden
von nervenzellen die pausenlos auf
sendung sind rund auf empfangen
darin soll unser bewusstsein und sich zu
hause sein aber wo genau wo stecken
unsere wahrnehmungen und gefühle und wo
unsere seele könnte es vielleicht sein
dass unser geist im grunde nichts
anderes ist als unser gehirn ist
letztlich alles nur materie also auch
wir selber nichts als materie
wer das glaubt kennt mary nicht sie ist
die führende expertin wenn es um die
wahrnehmung von farben geht
sie weiß alles über wellenlängen über
die retina vom auge und über die
verarbeitung von visuellen reizen im
gehirn sie kennt alle wissenschaftlichen
fakten und weist haargenau was vor sich
geht wenn wir haben ziele
der haken an der sache ist mary hat
selbst noch nie einen farbigen
gegenstand gesehen weder eine rote
tomaten noch den blauen himmel
sie befindet sich nämlich seit ihrer
geburt in einem raum in dem es keine
farben gibt ihre kleider sind
schwarz-weiß ihre haare schwarz sie
kennt nur schwarz weiß und grau alles
was sie über die welt und die
farbwahrnehmung weiß hat sie in büchern
gelesen
[Musik]
doch eines tages öffnet sich wie von
zauberhand die tür nach draußen
mary traut ihren augen kern auf einmal
sieht sie das was jahre lang erforscht
hat farbe
bisher wusste sie zwar sehr genau was in
ihrem gehirn passieren wird wenn sie
jemals farben sehen würde
nun aber
17 wie das ist
und wie es sich anfühlt für mary ist
klar sie hat 1000 etwas neues über
fahren gelernt ihr wissen über die
farbwahrnehmung war unvollständig
für sie ist damit auch klar es gibt
tatsachen die selbst eine perfekte
physikalische theorie nicht beschreiben
kann
[Musik]
ist unsere art die welt zu erleben also
etwas anderes als die biochemischen
vorgänge im gehirn ist unser geist mehr
als unser gehirn
[Musik]
das ist doch sehr überzeugend wurde dass
man das bewusstsein letztlich froh
ständigen war aus der innenperspektive
erfassen kann
jacksons gedankenexperiment mit der
farben wissenschaftlerin mary ist sehr
überzeugend
das klassische beispiel einer intuition
pumpe aber es ist falsch
ich bin froh dass jackson selbst es
widerrufen hat da es wie er begründet
nicht belege was er aussagen wollte
ich argumentiere seit jahren dagegen
denn es ist ein versagen der
vorstellungskraft
1991 habe ich deshalb in meinem buch
philosophie des menschlichen
bewusstseins den schluss von marys
geschichte leicht verändert wenn sich
die türe öffnet und sie zum ersten mal
fahren sieht zeigen ihr ihre kollegen
die sie eingeschlossen hatten eine blaue
übernahme sie stutzt und sagt das ist
eine blaue banane ihr wollt mich hinters
licht führen ihre kollegen sind
sprachlos
das kann sie doch nicht wissen doch das
kann sie wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
sie alles über die physikalischen
reaktionen ihres eigenen gehirns weiß
kann sie das problemlos entlarvt als
wären sie ihr ganzes leben lang nie mit
einem bleistift spitze berührt worden
hätten aber alles über bleistifte
gelesen weil ich sie nun mit einer
bleistift spitze berühre wenden sie ein
durch diese berührung erfahre ich nichts
neues das ist nur ein teil meiner kritik
an diesem experiment
ich meine es gibt noch ein anderes
berühmtes gedankenexperiment das mal
kurz zusammenfassen kann von von dem
amerikanischen philosoph thomas niggl
er sagt er nimmt fledermäuse und sagt
wir können alles über diese tiere wissen
wie sie schlafen wie sie sich
fortpflanzen wie sie messen und so
weiter aber ich werde auch nie wissen
wie es ist eine fledermaus zu sein
dieses qualitative bewusstsein da komme
ich nicht dran aber sie behalten doch
doch das bewusstsein ist von außen des
klägers war forschen ja tatsächlich wohl
die zusammen mit meiner doktorandin
carol league ins eine abhandlung
schreiben mit dem titel wie ist es eine
fledermaus zu sein was sie schließlich
publizierte war ein essay mit der
überschrift wie ist es langweilig und
engstirnig zu sein
es gibt ein subtiles problem mit tom
nagels argumentation in seinen
ausführungen beschreibt er ausführlich
die physiologie von fledermäusen
warum findet er das relevant wenn es
wichtig wäre wäre noch vieles andere
wichtig doch für seine behauptung wir
könnten uns nicht vorstellen die es ist
eine frida maus zu sein
liefert er keine argumente er insistiert
einfach darauf über die jahre
frustrierte und langweilte mich dass
immer mehr bis es mich schließlich nur
noch amüsiert ich habe gesehen wie seine
abhandlung von wissenschaftlern als
nagels resultate zitiert wenn man sie
genauer liest findet man aber kein
einziges argument
er geht davon aus dass wir uns nicht
vorstellen können wie es ist eine
fledermaus zu sein und seine argumente
sind lediglich bestätigung und seiner
these doch seine annahme ist ganz
einfach falsch wer annimmt es gebe
informationen aus unserem innern die wir
nicht wissenschaftlich erklären können
ist auf dem holzweg
übrigens
hatten toll und ich vor einem monat in
new york city ein kurzes improvisiertes
streitgespräch darüber dass online
verfügbar ist
darin gab sich nägel sehr selbstsicher
ich kenne ihn seit mehr als vierzig oder
fünfzig jahre
er fragte woher nimmt ihrer ansicht nach
die wissenschaft die rehe autoritär
machte daraus eine sache der autorität
es gibt die autorität der ich
perspektive und die autorität der
wissenschaft ich entgegnete von einer
autorität der ich-perspektive auszugehen
ist unsinn wir wissen sehr wenig über
unser eigenes bewusstsein und vieles was
wir zu wissen glauben ist falsch wir
wissen rein nichts über das trägermedium
des bewusstseins wir wissen nur einiges
über dessen inhalt ein inzwischen
pensionierter erforscher der künstlichen
intelligenz namens richard powers
schickte mir kürzlich einen brief in dem
er etwas kristallklar festhielt was ich
seither häufig zitiere zum vergleich wie
unser bewusstsein die umgebung wahrnimmt
nimmt er das gemälde einer landschaft
dieses kann man in der realen landschaft
hinstellen und mit dem original
vergleichen
das grün auf dem gemälde mit dem grün
der landschaft wie ihr sehen sowohl das
medium mit seinen eigenschaften als auch
die eigenschaften des dargestellten
originals und wir können unterschiede
und ähnlichkeiten erkennen
das können wir aber nicht mit unserer
eigenen erfahrung machen
wir haben keinen zugang zum medium
unseres bewusstseins
dieses besteht nur aus puls zügen in
neuronalen netzwerken und dazu haben wir
keinen zug aber es ist das medium und
die eigenschaften dieses mediums
bestimmen was wir empfinden
wir merken das ist uns nicht gelingt die
beiden medien miteinander zu vergleichen
sagen wir die quali das phänomenale
bewusstsein sehe die dinge die wir
anschauen und das stimmt einfach nicht
es ist bloß schlechte theorie es ist
intuitiv so überzeugend hat deswegen ich
möchte ich könnte ihnen stundenlang
zuhören dass sie merken dass ich möchte
noch einen schritt weiter gehen
sie sind einer der berühmtesten
atheisten neben richard dawkins den sie
ja sehr gut kennen mit dem sie 2003
zusammen die bewegung bereits gegründet
haben und da zählen sie dazu das waren
nicht wir
gegründet wurde die bewegung von zwei
großartigen pensionierten
hochschulprofessoren aus kalifornien
wir haben nur davon erfahren und darüber
berichtet wir waren die buden und ich
die schöpfer häufig nass werden ist dass
das für sie auch religion eine idee ist
die durch die evolution irgendwann
entstanden ist also der glaube an einen
gott sie selbst halten gott für eine
fiktion den bestimmten hinsicht nützlich
sein kann nicht interessiert erst mal
bevor wir über gott sprechen warum
konnten diese idee auf im laufe der
menschheit
warum fangen menschen oder tiere an gott
zu glauben
das kann ich nicht beweisen aber ich
habe eine sehr überzeugende und passende
geschichte
die meisten tiere sicher alle säugetiere
haben eine schreckreaktion passiert
etwas überraschendes das uns erschreckt
wollen wir sofort wissen was los ist
er und düst vielleicht in einer
winternacht zu ihren füßen und plötzlich
fällt draußen ja und springt auf wir
reagieren anders
wir belassen es nicht dabei nun springt
auf der welt und fragt auf seine weise
er ist das was ist das vielleicht ist es
ein eindringling wer weiß
einen akteur zu sehen wo keiner ist ist
evolutionstechnisch eine gute strategie
menschen tun was unsere vorfahren taten
waren nachts im wald wirtin irgendwelche
erschreckenden geräusche und meinten
einen baum kuppel zu sehen
[Musik]
ein entsprechenden bauen und die idee
verbreitet sich jemand fragt war das
wirklich ein sprechender baum nein das
gibt es nicht
doch das war eine vielleicht als sie ins
dorf zurückkehren geht das gerücht um
die ohren hat einen sprechenden baum
gehört und eines der unsichtbaren wesen
dieser gegend ist geboren
alle elfen kobolde das und vielen aus
dem volksglauben sind so entstanden aus
diesen wiederkehrenden fantasien die
durch überraschende erlebnisse ausgelöst
wurden die wir uns nicht erklären können
und jene geschichten überleben die
unvergesslich bleiben
die geschichten die sie ihren kindern
erzählen möchten so funktioniert das so
ist die vielgötterei entstanden im lauf
der evolution wurde daraus der
monotheismus und das wars aber warum
sind sie so sicher dass diese
wahrnehmung dass man da irgendwie etwas
zu sehen mal dass das fiktion sind und
dass die leute nicht sensibel sind für
einen bereich der realität der wirklich
da ist also was macht sie so sicher dass
es keinen gott gibt woher wissen sie das
wie weiß ich ob es den weihnachtsmann
nicht gibt den osterhasen das loch ness
monster
ich weiß es nicht vielleicht gibt es sie
tatsächlich aber ich bin ziemlich sicher
und saki wie richard dawkins
wahrscheinlich gibt es gott nicht und
ich meine sehr wahrscheinlich ich denke
die existenz gottes ist so
unwahrscheinlich wie die existenz des
weihnachtsmanns es tut mir leid wenn ich
kinder schockieren die diese sendung
aber das heißt sie können diese annahme
dieser hypothese nicht widerlegen
sondern sie sagen nur es spricht halt zu
wenig dafür es gibt keine beweise dass
es gott gibt ja aber in solchen fällen
gibt es oft gute gründe eine der
alternativen als die unwahrscheinlichste
zu sehen und sie ausrangiert
ein berühmtes beispiel er konnte nicht
beweisen dass es keine teekanne gibt die
den saturn umkreist vielleicht gibt es
ja eine teekanne im weltall
er kann das gegenteil nicht belegen aber
das ist nicht wichtig
darf ich vorstellen das ist dein nachbar
er ist zwar ein netter typ hat aber ein
paar seltsame überzeugungen zum beispiel
die hier
[Musik]
er glaubt zwischen der erde und dem
planeten mars kreise eine teekanne um
die sonne
[Musik]
bisher hat noch niemand diese teekanne
gesehen denn sie ist zu klein als dass
sie durch ein teleskop beobachtet werden
könnte dein nachbar nennen wir ihn einen
testen behauptet jedoch solange niemand
meine annahme widerlegen kann bleibe ich
bei meinem glauben was nicht widerlegt
ist daran darf geglaubt werden
doch stimmt das fakt ist es gibt
unzählige bizarre hypothesen die nicht
widerlegbar sind wie etwa die annahme
dass unsere welt von einem fliegenden
spaghettimonster geschaffen wurde
oder dass überall kleine rosa elefanten
sitzen die sich in luft auflösen sobald
wir hinschauen
diese annahmen lassen sich nicht
widerlegen
aber wer glaubt dass etwas existiert
braucht dafür gute gründe dass man es
nicht widerlegen kann allein reicht
nicht
sonst wären beliebig viele absurde
annahmen möglich aber was bedeutet das
für unsere nachbarn und seine tk wer hat
die richtige einstellung der teer ist
der an die existenz der teekanne glaube
der atheist der an ihre nichtexistenz
glaubt oder der skeptiker der weder an
ihrer existenz noch an ihren
nichtexistenz glaubt sondern meint man
wisse es eben nicht
[Musik]
und wie steht es um den glauben an die
existenz gottes ist er etwa so
irrational wie der glaube an ein
fliegendes spaghettimonster
macht es sinn an etwas zu glauben dessen
existenz sich nicht belegen lässt
ja ist der glaube ihr rational sondern
er diente einen sehr guten zweck der
glaube wurde nicht dafür erfunden aber
durch die natürliche selektion
kultureller überzeugungen trug er dazu
bei die hilfsbereitschaft zu stärken und
die gemeinschaft von stämmen und dörfern
von nicht miteinander verwandten
menschen zu festigen
anders gesagt die sozial bande der
erweiterten familie
ich gebe gerne zu dass die früher
religion bei der bildung von gruppen
identitäten eine wichtige rolle spielte
und den sozialen zusammenhalt ermöglicht
diese rolle ist heute weniger notwendig
ich sehe die religion als sehr wichtige
frühe stütze als eine prothese wenn sie
sowohl um die zivilisationen mit
demokratie wissenschaft freie presse und
all diesen guten errungenschaften
auszustatten
sie war der mutter dafür jetzt können
die religionen verschwinden
was können wir denn von religionen
lernen außer diesen dieser gemeinschaft
das ist das thema sind stiftung ist da
schon was zentrales und menschen die
gläubig sind spüren auch einen gewissen
halt in gewissem sinn in ihrem leben
wie ist das bei ihnen gibt es momente wo
sie sich wünschen
gläubig zu sein drei doppel immer ich
glaube ja an gewisse dinge und die
sinnstiftung macht das leben aus
aber wenn schon sollte man dinge
anstreben die wirklich von bedeutung
sind
ich musste mich einer schweren
herzoperation unterziehen
ich bekam eine künstliche arta da ich
einen riss in der aorta wand hatte
das ist normalerweise tödlich in meinem
fall nicht weil ein großartiges ärzte
pfleger und techniker team das richtige
tat um mein leben rettete das war 2006
vor bald zwölf jahren als ich mich im
krankenhaus erholte er sich amüsiert und
interessiert viele e mails in denen ich
gefragt wurde ob ich eine erleuchtung
gehabt und dem tod ins gesicht geschaut
hätte ich antwortete ja aber nicht so
wie es wohl erwartet habt mir wurde klar
was wir atheist meinen wenn wir denken
es sagen das ist kein verkapptes
gottseidank vielmehr dank
es gibt viel gutes in der welt
das verdanken wir nicht der güte gottes
sondern der güte von menschen der güte
der menschen die sich um mich gekümmert
habe er güte der ärzte und
wissenschaftler mit ihren forschungen
mit ihren medikamenten
wir alle sind nutznießer von unendlich
wie gutem dass menschen getan hat
deshalb empfehle ich dass wir dankbar
sind für all das was früher geleistet
wurde und das können die zurückgeben
nicht indem wir einer vater sie kreatur
tiere opfern sondern indem wir zum guten
beitrag gibt es weiter pflanzen anbauen
unterstütze ein waisenkind strecke etwas
wichtiges wie wählen
so können wir unsere dankbarkeit
ausdrücken für all die guten dinge die
geschehen sind
und von denen wir profitieren aber da
sind wir bei den moralischen werten wie
gerechtigkeit solidarität und so weiter
das müssten doch in ihrem weltbild auch
bloße fiktionen sein
also es gibt keine objektiven wert das
sind auch irgendwelche kulturellen
produkte die entstanden sind und
nützlich waren für uns vergessen sie
nicht was sie glaube ich vorhin selber
gesagt haben
illusionen können gutes benutzer
illusion ihres mobiltelefons ist
nützlich wir haben gewisse
übereinstimmende weltansichten die uns
mehr dienen als schaden sie als
illusionen zu bezeichnen ist ein wenig
unfair
es geht um das uralte philosophische
problem sind dinge gut weil gott denkt
sie seien gut oder denkt gott sie seien
gut weil sie gut sind aus meiner
philosophischen perspektive könnte man
sagen es gibt keine garantie dass etwas
gut ist weil jemand x-beliebiger es sagt
großtante lucille denkt es sei gut also
ist es gut wenn sie denn warum sollten
wir glauben was sie denkt ähnlich ist es
wenn sie an einen einzigen gott glauben
zuerst einmal wer sagt ihnen was dieser
gott denkt die geschichte ist voller
abscheulicher auffassungen von gott und
seinen überzeugungen und es wurde
dadurch viel leid verursacht was ist der
bessere weg
ich denke es liegt auf der hand denn
vermittler wegzulassen und in
politischen begriffen über die dinge
nachzudenken
stellen sie sich vor wir würden einen
kongress abhalten
eine öffentliche arena in der wie andere
überzeugen können was immer sie auch als
gut erachten wie es ist ihre chance der
welt mitzuteilen warum sie davon
überzeugt sind
aber sie dürfen nie die glaubens karte
ausspielen wenn sie sagen in meiner
religion wird nicht gut geheißen dass
man schweinefleisch ist ist das eine
tatsache
sagen sie uns warum wir das nicht tun
sollen aber sagen sie nicht all gott es
vorschreibt wenn es einen guten grund
dafür gibt sind wir einverstanden
es erwächst aus diesem rationalen
prozess es ist keine wissenschaftliche
schlussfolgerung sondern politische
überzeugungsarbeit
es geht um das ideal einen konsens zu
erzielen und dabei viele anliegen
unerledigt zu lassen wenn man sich auf
der welt umschaut gibt es praktiken an
die gewisse leute zutiefst glaube
während andre sie für unsinn halten wenn
sie niemandem schaden lassen wir sie
ihnen aber ich denke es gibt einen kern
existiert ein besseres fundament für die
moral als das was herauskommt wenn
menschen ermutigt werden gründlich
darüber nachzudenken sind leider schon
fast am ende dieses gesprächs ich habe
verstanden warum sie nicht an einen gott
klappen
draußen ist ich frage mich ist in ihm
drin auch eine spirituelle seite wenn
sie zum beispiel das segeln oder gute
jazz musik hören oder an das eigene
sterben denken gibt es der begriff
spielt uhl hat dem englischen
sprachgebrauch eine sehr hohe bedeutung
erlangt doch dadurch wurde auch seine
ursprüngliche bedeutung verwässert die
spiritualität gewisser leute ist der
profifußball wahrheit demokratie
autonomie das sind für mich hohe werte
und ich bin überaus dankbar dass es
musik und kunst gibt die mich manchmal
zu tränen das finde ich wunderbar es ist
noch wunderbarer für mich wenn ich
realisiere dass johann sebastian bach
kein engel kein gott niemand
übernatürlicher aber ein großartiges
produkt der natürlichen selektion sein
geist war wunderbar ausgestattet mit
werkzeugen kulturelle selektion
daraus entstanden werke die umwerfend
schön sind und die ganze menschheit
berühren das ist gut genug für mich
ich will die bank nicht mehr schätzen
wenn mir jemand glaubhaft machen könnte
dass irgendein gott bach eine chemie
pille
das wäre für mich wie bitte
die freude ist ganz meinerseits
das waren gute fragen
[Musik]